[Música]
llegamos al momento hablar de salud ya
está en el estudio más romeros a la
lista para hablar entonces de la
pandemia mar pero empezamos en madrid
porque las listas de espera para la
sanidad pública en la capital española
se han multiplicado desde la pandemia de
ccoo y 19 que sabemos sobre este
problema mar pues es un problema que
crece y crece desde hace semanas
actualmente ya son 750.000 los
madrileños que están esperando a poderse
hacer cirugías a poderse visitar con
especialistas a poder hacerse pruebas
médicas de eso para hacernos una idea
representa el 11 por ciento de la
población de la capital española esos
niveles son niveles nunca vistos antes y
precisamente por eso el aura cambón
nuestra periodista en la capital
española nos detalla con más precisión
qué pasa con esta situación
es la primera vez que la comunidad de
madrid supera el medio millón de
pacientes en lista de espera para un
especialista entre ellos conocimos a
paul es repartidor en bicicleta tuvo un
accidente en julio tiene que ver a un
fisioterapeuta pero no le dan cita y
mientras no puede trabajar si miranda
una terapia ya su mes y medio y estudiar
pero realmente
pero tarda una terapia tardó más de un
mes y medio y no tengo terapias las
rodillas y inflamadas y sigo sin poder
caminar sigo sin poder hacer prácticas
físicas sin esfuerzo físico nada hay que
sumar 150 mil personas que aguardan una
prueba diagnóstica y 100 mil personas
que esperan una operación las listas de
espera para los centros de salud también
se han incrementado en un 36 por ciento
en menos de un año según la doctora
maría justicia la calidad asistencial se
ha empeorado tenemos listas de pacientes
que superan en muchos casos 50 60 70
pacientes al día cosa que
es inconcebible en otros países fuera de
españa
el tiempo de asistencia por paciente en
muchos casos no supera a los cinco
minutos y hay veces muchas veces que
tenemos a dos tres y cuatro pacientes
citados en el mismo minuto a nivel de
españa las listas de espera han vuelto a
los niveles anteriores a la pandemia
pero aún así siguen muy largos por
ejemplo para una operación se tiene que
esperar de media 121 días
gracias entonces al informe nuestra
corresponsal en madrid del aura a campo
para ver esta situación sanitaria que se
vive en la capital española vamos ahora
a dejar a un lado la pandemia y madrid
porque la organización mundial de la
salud pidió que se elimine el cáncer de
cuello uterino marc no es una meta tan
descabellada y veces que estas
organizaciones piden metas que nos
parecen imposibles de alcanzar pero en
este caso no es tan difícil porque
porque al final este cáncer es uno de
los más fáciles de prevenir hay una
vacuna contra el virus del papiloma
humano que es el principal causante del
cáncer y se detecta si se detecta
temprano es muy fácil que las personas
puedan sobrevivir sin embargo a día de
hoy sigue provocando 300.000 muertes
anuales escuchemos lo que dijo la
organización mundial de la salud en
medellin camps countries y en países de
ingresos bajos y medios hay dos veces
más incidencia de cáncer cervical y tres
veces más mortalidad que en los países
de ingresos altos así hay income también
vemos desigualdades parecidas en
poblaciones marginalizadas dentro de los
mismos países en ricos mary jane campion
crist
es lamentable por ejemplo nueve de cada
diez mujeres que mueren por cáncer de
cuello uterino lo hacen en países
precisamente de ingresos bajos o de
ingresos medios por qué sucede eso pues
la respuesta también está a veces en las
cifras de la misma organización mundial
de la salud y es que estos países de
ingresos bajos de ingresos medios no
tienen acceso a la vacuna por ejemplo el
25 por ciento o el 30 por ciento de los
países en la escala más baja de recursos
no tienen acceso a la vacuna contra el
virus del papiloma humano una cifra
totalmente dispar cuando se compara con
los países ricos donde el 85 por ciento
de sus gobiernos distribuyen con
regularidad la vacuna contra el virus
del papiloma humano parte de la razón
también de esta desigualdad es el coste
que tiene esta esta vacuna no hay tres
vacunas aprobadas contra el virus del
papiloma humano dos de la farmacéutica
merck una de glaxosmithkline y el
tratamiento que son varias dosis pueden
llegar a costar entre 300 y 500 dólares
por persona un precio totalmente
inasequible ni para las personas ni para
los gobiernos de los países que no
tienen recursos y lo peor de todo además
raúl es que hace poco se supo había un
estudio que nombramos aquí mismo que
éste que esta vacuna realmente funciona
cuando sea en reino unido en niñas entre
12 y 13 años había reducido casi en un
90 los casos de cáncer de cuello uterino
maroussi se habla de esa vacuna pero le
pregunté entonces cómo se desarrolló
este antídoto este antídoto pues me
gusta mucho que me hagas esa pregunta
porque me gusta mucho la historia
entonces vamos a hablar brevemente de
eso y es que la vacuna contra el virus
del papiloma humano se logró desarrollar
en parte gracias a unas células muy
especiales que secan en las células
hella que vienen del nombre henrieta la
chs ella era una mujer negra de clase
trabajadora que vivía en eeuu y que los
años 50 se acercó a un hospital de
baltimore al hospital johns hopkins de
hecho que era el único que atendía uno
de los únicos que tendría personas
negras en el país en ese momento porque
tenía síntomas precisamente de cáncer de
cuello uterino efectivamente
descubrieron que tenía un tumor muy
agresivo que terminó con su vida sólo
nueve meses después de haber acudido a
la consulta a los 31 años pero el motivo
por el cual esta mujer pasó a la
historia es que le extrajeron una
muestra de estas que células cancerosas
sin su consentimiento y sin su
conocimiento y descubrieron el huevo en
fuera de la consulta que estas células
estaba produciendo de manera
prácticamente infinita precisamente por
un cambio introducido en su adn por el
virus del papiloma humano parecía que
estas células nuncas envejecían se
podían reproducir de manera infinita y
cuando descubrieron esa especie de
milagro médico era la primera vez que
sucedía empezaron a distribuirse ya
comercializarse para poder realizar
estudios en pues de mucho de distintas
índoles no a día de hoy por ejemplo ya
casi 60 años después han distribuido 50
millones de toneladas métricas de este
tipo de células de esta línea celular se
han usado en más de 75.000 estudios
entre los cuales está la vacuna contra
la polio y también la vacuna contra el
virus del papiloma humano en procesos de
fecundación in vitro pues pero pues
también se denuncia que ha sido uno de
los actos más racistas de la historia no
extraer sin su consentimiento células de
una mujer negra enferma pobre y luego
pues se han ganado premios nobel se han
hecho fortunas gracias a estas células
es un reflejo al final que hoy en día
todavía hay a mujeres como en riad a las
que mueren por por ejemplo por este
cáncer de cuello uterino porque no
tienen acceso a una vacuna que se
desarrolló gracias también a otro acto
racista pues más mañana nos vemos con
más salud para